we've all done the worst kinds of things
just to stay alive but we can still come
back we're not too far gone hey
youtubers is Charlie and what the hell
just happened on Walking Dead there are
so many surprises during the episode
that I'm gonna do my top 5 WTF moments
and then I'll do my review so many
things to talk about so let's get
started number 5 megan gets bitten so
the minute that that walker started
crossing the river
I was just sitting on the edge of my
chair but the minute the dirt starts to
rustle on the ground I just stop
breathing
you just know that the minute that
Walker sinks his teeth into her it's all
over her death is like that first domino
that just knocks over all the other
people that get murdered during the
episode number 4 the governor shoots
Megan in the head after he finds out
what happened this happened after the
[ __ ] hit the fan to prison so the
governor was already full-on crazy but I
never predicted that he would just shoot
her without even giving it a second
thought
just a look on Lois face while she was
watching that happen to she was
basically seeing the governor for the
monster he was number 3 the prison dies
so the biggest death in this prison
wasn't Herschel wasn't Megan it was the
prison itself it was like a paradise
like an I in the Walker storm that was
surrounding them but like all things
paradise cannot last so they are cast
out of heaven if you consider that
heaven number 2 the governor's death so
david morrissey confirmed the governor
is gone he said he had to die because
he'd just basically done the worst thing
he could possibly do when he killed
Meghan and then - he killed Hershel
there's no coming back from that
but Robert Kirkman said something really
interesting he said that in the comics
somebody different killed the governor
it was an unknown character and wasn't
really satisfying so on the show they
changed it so obviously Michonne runs
him through and then Lilly finishes the
job which I thought was totally
appropriate early on I actually kind of
predicted that the governor's new family
would turn on him and they would either
maybe try to kill him or just abandon
him another - I actually kind of guessed
that Terah would have been the one to
kill him given the chance and my number
one WTF moment the governor kills
Hershel so this was the most traumatic
death in the episode Hershel was kind of
like everyone's dad at the prison he was
at the moral compass for that group so
what's gonna happen now that he's gone
they're all kind of scattered to the
wind and everyone's just losing their
[ __ ] I'm talking dad Kirkman actually
said that Hershel was supposed to die in
the second season but because he worked
so well as this moral compass for the
group they kept him on he decided this
nice moral dynamic to the show that they
thought was really interesting and now
that he's gone it'll be really interests
to see where these characters turn to
for moral guidance but let me know in
the comments what are your top WTF
moments from this episode and what do
you think is going to happen to the
group now that they're all splintered so
remember there was the group on the bus
and then there was a group that fled in
the woods the show doesn't come back
till February 9th but I'll be doing
bonus videos this month and in January
so be sure to subscribe to get them
overall this is actually my new favorite
episode from season 4 so far I love the
way that they killed Hershel and the
governor because those characters are so
big and they've been around for so long
you have to kill them in a way that
feels satisfying and I feel like they
really accomplish that goal
Hershel had that smile on his face I
thought that was really appropriate for
his character he kind of felt like he
had taught Rick everything he could
teach him and Rick understood what he
needed to do the governor on the other
hand had hit rock bottom so david
morrissey said that it was time to say
goodbye so I totally agree with that
statement there's really nowhere you can
go with the character after he did that
things lead in this episode after
killing Hershel that's one of the most
unforgivable things you do you killed
the moral center of a group I also
thought the way Hershel died by getting
decapitated was a nice callback to his
speech in the third episode gray said
you stick your neck out now that we've
had eight episodes so far though in our
mid-season finale let me know in the
comments what is your favorite episode
from this season so far and how do you
think they're gonna top that whenever
the season comes back in February right
now click here to get last week's
Walking Dead video and click here to get
my top 5 most anticipated moments for
Sherlock series 3 that's coming back in
January thanks so much for watching high
fives I'll see you guys tomorrow